INFORMANT'S LAWYER.
VICTORIA TOENSING.
FIRST WE GET TO TONIGHT'S
BREAKING NEWS OPENING
MONOLOGUE.
♪
TEXT MESSAGES FROM TRUMP
HATING FBI OFFICIALS PETER
PUT OUT A REPORT THAT IS
INVESTIGATION.
NOW, DURING A SEPTEMBER 2ND,
FBI DIRECTOR JAMES COMEY TO
GIVE TO PRESIDENT BARACK
WANTS TO KNOW EVERYTHING
WE'RE DOING.
ALL RIGHT.
SO, WHAT EXACTLY DID
NOW, SOURCES CLOSE TO STRZOK
AND PAGE ARE TELLING THE
"WALL STREET JOURNAL"
TONIGHT THAT THIS MESSAGE
THEY SENT DOESN'T HAVE TO DO
WITH THE CLINTON EMAIL PROBE
AND, INSTEAD, WAS TALKING
ABOUT POSSIBLE RUSSIAN
INTERFERENCE IN THE
ELECTION.
SO, IN LIGHT OF THE NEW
STRZOK TEXTS WE NEED TO KNOW
WHAT INVESTIGATION IS OBAMA
WANT TO BE BRIEFED ON?
FOR BARACK OBAMA AND FRANKLY
EVERYONE ELSE INVOLVED IN
THIS SCANDAL.
TAKE A QUICK LOOK.
>> WHAT DID THE PRESIDENT
KNOW AND WHEN DID HE KNOW IT
IT?
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT.
THAT WAS SENATOR HOWARD
BAKER DURING THE WATERGATE
INVESTIGATION ASKING VERY
IMPORTANT QUESTIONS OF
PRESIDENT BARACK OBAMA AND
EVERYBODY.
WHAT DID REACH OUT -- WE DID
REACH OUT TO OBAMA'S
SPOKESPERSON.
WE DIDN'T GET COMMENT TO ALL
OF THEM.
BY THE WAY SHOCKING.
ALSO TONIGHT THERE IS A NEW
BATCH OF TEXT MESSAGES JUST
RELEASED FROM TRUMP-HATING
FBI LOVERS PETER STRZOK AND
LISA PAGE.
IT HIGHLIGHTS THEIR
INVESTIGATIVE BIAS AND, OF
COURSE, THEIR CONTINUED
HATRED OF DONALD TRUMP.
ON AUGUST 9TH, 2016 LISA
PEANEL WRITES WELL HE IS NOT
EVER GOING TO BECOME
NOVEMBER 3RD, 2016, ONLY
DAYS BEFORE THE ELECTION,
PAGE WROTE WELL THE "NEW
YORK TIMES" PROBABILITY
NUMBERS ARE DROPPING EVERY
SINGLE DAY.
I'M SCARED FOR OUR
ORGANIZATION.
NOW, THE SENATE REPORT NOTES
THIS IS LIKELY A REFERENCE
TO THE "NEW YORK TIMES"
ELECTION FORECAST WHICH
SHOWED TRUMP GAINING GROUND
AT THAT POINT IN THE
ELECTION.
THEN, ON ELECTION DAY,
NOVEMBER 8TH, 2016, STRZOK
THEN SAYS OH MY GOD, THIS IS
BLANKING TERRIFYING.
AND THE NEXT DAY STRZOK
FOLLOWS UP WITH A OH MY GOD,
I AM SO DEPRESSED.
AND A FEW DAYS LATER ON
TEXTS, PAY CLOSE ATTENTION
TO THIS.
WELL I BOUGHT ALL THE
PRESIDENT'S MEN I FIGURED I
NEEDED TO BRUSH UP ON
WATERGATE.
THE FOLLOWING DAY PEANG
WRITES GOD, BEING HERE MAKE
SECURITY TALK AND MEANWHILE
WE HAVE OUR TASK AHEAD OF
US.
OKAY, WHAT TASK ARE THEY
TALKING ABOUT?
NOW, STRZOK AND PAGE ALSO
CALLED TRUMP AN IDIOT,
LOATHE SOME HUMAN BEING AND
CLEARLY THINK WERE ABUSIVELY
BIASED TOWARDS NOW PRESIDENT
IMPORTANT.
PETER STRZOK AND TO AN
EXTENT LISA PAGE WHO WAS
ANDREW MCCABE'S LEGAL
COUNSEL, THEY ARE AT THE
CENTER OF EVERYTHING IN ALL
OF THIS.
NOW, STRZOK WAS A FORMER TOP
INTELLIGENCE OFFICIAL AT THE
FBI AND SIGNED THE
DOCUMENTS, REMEMBER, TO
START THE RUSSIA
INVESTIGATION.
AND STRZOK ALSO PLAYED A KEY
ROLE IN THE CLINTON
INVESTIGATION.
EVEN INTERVIEWS HILLARY AND
HELPING JAMES COMEY WRITE
THAT EXONERATION MONTHS
BEFORE THE INVESTIGATION.
AND, OF COURSE, BY
GENERAL FLYNN.
THAT ALLOWED HILLARY CLINTON
TO REMAIN IN THIS
PRESIDENTIAL RACE.
OTHERWISE, VERY-LIKELY IF IT
WAS A FAIR INVESTIGATION,
AND A NEW TEXT MESSAGE
PROVES THAT ON
SEPTEMBER 28TH, 2016, STRZOK
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
EMAILS TURNED OVER BY
WEINER'S ATTORNEY TO THE
YORK, INCLUDES A TON OF
MATERIAL FROM SPOUSE.
THAT MEANS HUMA ABEDIN,
SENDING TEAM UP TOMORROW TO
REVIEW.
THIS WILL NEVER END.
ACCORDING TO REPORTS, WHAT
CAUSED ANDREW MCCABE TO
ABRUPTLY RESIGN AT THE END
OF LAST MONTH AND THE "WALL
STREET JOURNAL'S" REPORTING
THAT THE FBI OFFICIALS, TOP
OFFICIALS, INCLUDING MCCABE,
THEY KNEW ABOUT HUMA
ABEDIN'S EMAILS THAT WERE
FOUND ON ANTHONY WEINER'S
LAPTOP IN SEPTEMBER OF 2016,
BUT THEY WAITED FOR AT LEAST
ALERTING CONGRESS.
THAT TEXT MESSAGE PROVIDES
VERY KEY PROOF THAT SHOW
THAT COMEY, MCCABE AND
OTHERS LITERALLY SAT AT A
HAVE DONE.
IG'S REPORT DUE OUT IN
SPRING HOPEFULLY MARCH AND
QUESTIONS WILL BE ANSWERED.
RAISING A LOT OF RED FLAGS
TONIGHT.
STRZOK WAS TALKING ABOUT
JOINING THE INVESTIGATION
WITH MUELLER AND STRZOK
ASKED PAGE THIS QUESTION:
AN INVESTIGATION LEADING TO
IMPEACHMENT?
WHY ARE THEY TALKING ABOUT
KEEP IN MIND, DURING THAT
SAME TEXT HE
SAME TEXT EE
SAME TEXT EXCHANGE ON
MAY 19TH, TWO DAYS AFTER
ROBERT MUELLER WAS NAMED
SPECIAL COUNSEL STRZOK SAYS
WELL YOU AND I BOTH KNOW THE
ODDS ARE NOTHING.
IF I THOUGHT IT WAS LIKELY,
I WOULD BE THERE NO
QUESTION.
I HESITATE IN PART BECAUSE
THAT THERE'S NO BIG THERE
THERE.
HUH.
SO STRZOK KNEW FROM THE
START THAT MUELLER WOULD BE
CARRYING OUT A WITCH-HUNT
PRETTY MUCH.
THERE IS ALSO NEW
REVELATIONS ABOUT FORMER
ATTORNEY GENERAL LORETTA
LYNCH AND HER INVOLVEMENT IN
THE CLINTON EMAIL COVERUP.
IN JUNE 2016, BILL CLINTON
INFAMOUSLY MEETS WITH
LORETTA LYNCH ON THE TARMAC
IN PHOENIX FOR 40 MINUTES
WHICH CAUSED LORETTA LYNCH
TO SAY ON JULY 1st SHE IS
STEPPING AWAY FROM THE
CONCLUSION.
NOW, KEEP IN MIND, ALL OF
THIS IS BEFORE HILLARY
CLINTON WAS EVER INTERVIEWED
BY THE FBI.
SO, AFTER LYNCH'S STATEMENT
COMEY, THE SAME GUY THAT SHE
SAID DON'T CALL IT AN
INVESTIGATION, CALL IT A
MATTER, STRZOK THEN WRITES
AND PAGE REPLIES YEAH,
IT'S A REAL PROFILE IN
COURAGE SINCE SHE, LORETTA
LYNCH KNOWS NO CHARGES WILL
BE BROUGHT.
BY THE WAY THEY HADN'T
INTERVIEWED HILLARY YET.
FOUR DAYS LATER COMEY HOLDS
HIS PRESS CONFERENCE RIGHT
STRZOKENS INTERVIEW AND THEY
LET CLINTON OFF THE HOOK.
SO PAGE, STRZOK, LORETTA
LYNCH, COMEY ALL KNEW THAT
ADMINISTRATION, IN FACT, WAS
RIGGING IT APPEARED THE FIX
WAS IN.
EVIDENCE THAT THE FBI LIED
TO A FISA COURT USING THAT
CAMPAIGN.
HERE ARE THE HIGHLIGHTS IF
YOU WEREN'T WITH US.
THE PHONY DOSSIER IN FACT
DID MAKE UP THE BULK OF THAT
FISA APPLICATION.
WAS CREDIBLE.
SO COMEY, HE JUST TRUSTED
STEELE.
WHY BOTHER VERIFYING IT?
HE DIDN'T.
NOW THE FBI ONLY VAGUELY
REFERENCED THE DOSSIER'S
POLITICAL ORIGINS TO THE
FISA COURT.
SO WHAT THEY WERE DOING WAS
HIDING THE FACT.
THEY DIDN'T TELL THE FISA
COURT JUDGE IN THEIR
APPLICATION THAT THAT
DOSSIER, THAT THEY DIDN'T
VERIFY, WAS BOUGHT AND PAID
FOR BY HILLARY CLINTON.
NOW, THE SENATORS ALSO
REMEMBER WE TOLD YOU LAST
FED INFORMATION FROM THE
OBAMA STATE DEPARTMENT AND
CLINTON CRONIES.
LITERALLY CLINTON'S FRIENDS
ARE GIVING STEELE SOME OF
THE INFORMATION IS HE USING
IN THAT PHONY DOSSIER BUT
THE REST OF THE INFORMATION
CAME FROM THE RUSSIAN
GOVERNMENT, REMEMBER?
I WAS SAYING THE GOVERNMENT
WAS THE SOURCE OF THE PHONY
DOSSIER MATERIAL.
BRITISH COURT RECORDS,
STEELE TALKED TO REPORTERS,
LET'S SEE FROM THE "NEW YORK
TIMES," FAKE NEWS, "THE
WASHINGTON POST," YAHOO
NEWS, NEW YORKER AND, OF
COURSE, THE NETWORK CNN 2016
ABOUT THE DOSSIER.
WE PREVIOUSLY UNCOVERED THAT
FUSION GPS CO-FOUNDER,
REMEMBER GLENN SIMPSON HE
ACTUALLY TESTIFIED TO A
DNC WERE VERY AWARE THAT HIS
COMPANY WAS CONTACTING MEDIA
OUTLETS.
THEY WERE COORDINATING, IN
OTHER WORDS, ABOUT THE
DOSSIER.
COORDINATING THEIR EFFORTS
TO LEAK THESE RUSSIAN LIES.
AND ALSO REMEMBER, THE
SENATE REPORT SAYS THE
DOSSIER, AS WE TOLD YOU LAST
NIGHT, FULL OF INFORMATION
FROM THE RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT.
COLLUSION STORY.
HILLARY, RUSSIA, COLLUSION.
AND, OF COURSE, THERE'S THE
REPUBLICAN HOUSE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE MEMO,
REMEMBER THE HIGHLIGHTS FROM
THAT DOCUMENT, THE FORMER
DEPUTY FBI DIRECTOR ANDREW
MCCABE REVEALED TO CONGRESS
WITHOUT THAT DOSSIER, THE
FISA WARRANT TO SURVEIL
WOULD NEVER HAVE BEEN
APPROVED.
NOW, THE FISA JUDGE WAS, IN
FACT, IN THIS PARTICULAR
CASE NEVER NOTIFIED THAT THE
DOSSIER WAS BOUGHT AND PAID
FOR, AGAIN, BY THE THE
HILLARY CLINTON AND THE DNC
FUNNELED THROUGH THE SAME
LAW FIRM, WHICH OF COURSE
IS, A HUGE PROBLEM.
AND WE ALSO KNOW THAT JAMES
COMEY, ANDREW MCCABE, SALLY
YATES, DANA AND ROD
ROSENSTEIN, ALL APPROVED
SURVEYING IN THIS PARTICULAR
CASE.
NOW, THE FBI ALSO USED THE
YAHOO NEWS ARTICLE WRITTEN
BY MICHAEL ISIKOFF ABOUT THE
CARTER TRIP TO RUSSIA.
THEY WERE USING IT AS
PHONY DOSSIER BEFORE THE
FISA JUDGE.
EXCEPT THE SOURCE FOR THE
YAHOO STORY WAS OF COURSE
CHRISTOPHER STEELE.
BECAUSE STEELE WAS THE
SOURCE OF THE DOSSIER AND
FAKE NEWS SORRY BY MICHAEL
ISIKOFF.
WE ALSO KNOW NO ONE
EVER VERIFIED WHAT WAS IN
THE DOSSIER.
THE MEMO SHOWS STEELE WAS
SUSPENDED AND TERMINATED AS
OFFICIAL BRUCE OHR HAD A
CLOSE RELATIONSHIP WITH
STEELE.
REMEMBER, OHR IS THE GUY WHO
HAD AN OFFICE FOUR DOORS
DOWN FROM THE DEPUTY
ATTORNEY GENERAL ROD
ROSENSTEIN WHO WOULD LATER
APPOINT ROBERT MUELLER AND
OHR'S WIFE NELLIE WANT TO
TALK ABOUT JUST COINCIDENCES
IN LIFE?
OHR'S WIFE WAS EMPLOYED BY
FUSION GPS, SPECIFICALLY
WORKING ON THE ANTI-TRUMP
OPPOSITION RESEARCH.
AND BRUCE OHR SAID THAT
STEELE SAID, QUOTE:  HE WAS
DESPERATE.
THE AUTHOR OF THE DOSSIER
DESPERATE NOT GET ELECTED
AND WAS PASSIONATE ABOUT HIM
NOT BEING PRESIDENT.
FINALLY TONIGHT, THE MEMO
FINDS DURING THE FIRST FISA
APPLICATION FOR THAT
WARRANT, CORROBORATION OF
THE STEELE DOSSIER WAS, IN
QUOTE, ITS INFANCY STAGE.
HILLARY AND THE DNC.
SO THE FBI LIED TO A FISA
COURT JUDGE.
THEY USED THE DOSSIER FULL
OF RUSSIAN LIES TO SPY ON
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN JUST
BEFORE AN PERSON PERSON WHO
ELECTION.
WEAPONIZED TO SPY ON